we've refound quite an exciting piece of
video in our archive not really in the
archive in a cardboard box on the floor
in the basement
it shows exploding pianos being studied
in this building or rather outside it
and it's quite an exciting story our
former colleague Colonel Biddy Shah who
was a lecturer here and expert in
explosives he fortunately first of all
was asked to be an expert witness in the
court case the BBC used to have a show
music show called the Billy cotton band
show which was really quite an important
show on the television I remember it
always opened with Billy cotton the band
master saying wakey-wakey in a way that
I can't really imitate
and there were also lots of dancing
women in a way that would now be
considered extremely sexist anyway the
exploding piano occurred in the photo
shoot before one of his programs and
they were filming a pianist called Alan
breeze playing on the piano as it was
wheeled on a cart some sort of cart and
the idea of this sketch was that the
piano would explode at some time during
the song they were singing the explosion
was going to be caused by a sort of
firework known as a flash pot the sort
of things that are normally used in
films for battle scenes all by real
armies when they're training soldiers so
they make quite a bang one of the
technicians had the idea of adding some
flour to make more white smoke now you
probably seen on our videos before that
if you take powders like Lycopodium you
can cause quite a flash when they catch
fire it was a really dumb idea because
when they let it off the piano exploded
several people were seriously injured
it's not clear now but somebody may have
even lost an eye and as a result of this
there was a court case and biddy Shaw
was brought in I think to try and decide
whether it was the fault of the people
who made the flash pots or it was the
flour that brings us the film because BD
Shaw shot film of his experiments which
presumably was then going to be shown in
the court case to show the results and
it's a really nice piece of scientific
research because first of all they look
at what happens when the flash pots
explode there were two sorts from two
different manufacturers Payne and Brock
then as the second stage they let off a
minute flash pot with some flour with a
box over the top
from what you can see probably looks
like an ammunition box it was not long
after the Second World War and you could
get these boxes that bullets were kept
in and you can see they fly up to really
quite a large height the final stage was
to try the flash pots in the pianos and
I have to explain then those days pianos
were very cheap lots of people had
pianos in their houses and they were
being thrown out because they were
buying record players televisions and so
on so it wasn't an expensive experiment
and so they decided to blow up some
pianos beginning with just the flash
pots and then putting in more and more
flour and you can see when they got the
recipe right or perhaps you would say
the recipe wrong there was really quite
an explosion and practically nothing at
all left of the piano and even now it
makes quite good viewing watching these
pianos blowing up
the other thing which is quite
interesting is that the place where the
explosion was done was behind exactly
the same building where Pete and Neal in
more recent times on our videos have let
off caesium and potassium so there is
really quite a long tradition there is
one quite serious message for all of you
who are scientists now or going to be
scientists which is that BD Shah and his
colleagues left this nice video but they
didn't leave proper lab records so we
can't get the most out of the video
because nowhere do we have the
description of exactly what the
experiments were so when you do your
next experiment make sure you write down
what you're doing so that in 50 years
time 70 years time people can find your
experiment and understand what you did
isn't the more important lesson don't
put a bunch of flair and your Flash well
yes I suppose if you're lucky enough to
have a piano first of all don't put a
flash pot in it and if you have to keep
away from the flower